Venus's hellish landscape is a glimpse
into Earth's future there will be no
more rain there will be no more oceans
this wonderful life friendly environment
we enjoy now just won't be here in some
hundreds of millions of years earth
could be an unimaginably terrible place
right now we live just the right
distance from the Sun where it's the
right temperature for water to exist as
a liquid but that's going to change just
as it did for Venus Venus started off
probably in the habitable zone and then
the inner limit to the habitable zone
crust the the distance of Venus's orbit
well it's going to cross the distance of
Earth's orbit - there is an expiration
date to the earth and that's due to the
sun's evolution ever since its birth the
Sun has been getting hotter
that increased heat devastated Venus and
in the future it will destroy earth
in 1.1 billion years the Sun is 10%
hotter than today the oceans start to
evaporate into thick clouds which trap
more of the sun's heat catastrophic ly
very rapidly on a geological timescale
the oceans will put so much water vapor
into the atmosphere that we will get a
runaway greenhouse effect the clouds
forming in the atmosphere trap more and
more heat driving temperatures even
higher
spiralling temperatures cause more
evaporation so the clouds get thicker
which led to more heating which led to
more evaporation and you can see where
this is going it's a vicious cycle it's
a positive feedback all of the oceans
water will boil away millions of cubic
miles of it
we have all of this water that will go
into the atmosphere covering the earth
and shrouding it and basically steam
Earth has had oceans for billions of
years but it could lose them in just
10,000
all
be in the atmosphere will have an
incredibly dense cloud comfort system
where the temperatures on earth will be
approaching a thousand degrees like
Venus in the past earth will get hotter
and hotter
but unlike Venus which topped out at 900
degrees temperatures on earth will keep
on climbing